in case you missed it Google I O was
last week bringing some exciting
generative AI announcements Palm 2 for
text and chat is now available to
everyone through vertex AI let's take a
look at what you can do to get started
there's three easy ways to access via
API and vertex AI model Gardens you can
easily plug into your applications or
deploy to a data science notebook with
built-in mlops tooling or use a simple
UI in generative AI studio for easy
experimentation with prompt design
there's many ways to prompt a model
let's take a look at three first a zero
shot prompt is where you simply tell the
model what you want with a few shot
prompting you can provide instruction
and examples to your model and a
structured prompt makes it really easy
to do view shot prompting you can
provide context for how the model should
respond and examples check out the link
in our description to learn more and
take a deeper dive into all the
generative AI announcements from Google
I O